hi guys good morning who's that who's
that who's that for that just kidding
so today we are gonna go have some
breakfast so you guys are gonna join us
while we go to IHOP and it's gonna be
the first time we go to IHOP and for
ever
we're gonna history we used to go to
IHOP almost every single time we met up
like every single time we would meet up
early eating days yeah it would always
be the I hope of my house and Downey and
we're the IHOP over here oh yeah or
Monterey Park so it would always be
these I hops that we would always go to
and then that's how like we would bond
like with Isaac remember we'd have
breakfast and then we saw we'd go have
breakfast important Gio in that time and
then we still always just have good time
so we are feeling a little nostalgic so
we're gonna go have some breakfast
alright so now we're on our way to go
eat and we are using our old camera for
this vlog so I don't know if you guys
noticed if it looks different or not but
this is the first camera that we bought
and the reason why we're using this
camera is because as you guys have
noticed our other camera has a dead
pixel so towards the top a little red
die it's been annoying a lot of you guys
so we're taking that camera in to get
fixed and we're using this old baby put
more red dots everywhere send our u-haul
yeah so that's why we're using the
and the reason why we stopped using this
camera it's this camera gets on my
nerves because it will it refuses to
focus on the right things like sometimes
like if I'm talking to the camera it
will focus behind me and I bet you
anything at some point in this vlog
that's gonna happen well the one thing
the one positive thing about this camera
that I like over the other cameras we
own is that this one is way more
portable it's like smaller and it could
just fit in my purse the other ones are
too bulky yeah so breakfast time I'm
hungry
[Music]
[Music]
I was showing it we're gonna be quite a
bit
and I really hope you can because it's
really loud in here but yeah we're going
to Vegas this weekend and just after
breakfast we
American Red Cross and feel with the
dummy blood Lina's since we're trying to
donate blood up to this I'm gonna try to
get a meal because I read that iron-rich
true red meat is part bad little
don't have lenses here but I'm gonna try
to get like a for something with a big
side is finished I could really up my
iron level I thought I was like why how
come we got this small one there looked
around at the other table as everyone
has a small copper thing a big plate of
spinach for my iron this is a lot of
food I am 100% sure I'm not gonna finish
this
to harvest
raining night I got pancakes too am I
gonna finish all of the dishes and
pancakes I didn't expect to get
hashbrowns so that's something I didn't
know it's gonna be potatoes are cheap
all right so breakfast is over
it was delicious are you folding it very
full no sleepy I know I know we got it
getting the itis so I did my best
finishing what I could and I'm actually
pretty proud of myself compared to how I
how much I usually eat I eat a lot this
time right yeah you do your appetites
growing I don't think it's growing I
think it was just today anyways we're on
our way now to the American Red Cross
earlier this week I kept trying to book
an appointment for us to go and donate
blood in Las Vegas yeah in Las Vegas
since we're going to Vegas like we
wanted our blood to go directly to the
victims but and I called and they said
that they don't have any appointments
available until the end of October so
we're like okay well we're not gonna be
there at that time but they did say that
we can just go to any donation center
and just donate our blood and no matter
what what is always needed so I did try
to see if I can book an appointment for
the center's around us or see if there's
any blood drives around us but
everything around us is pretty booked
they did say on the website that
walk-ins are welcome so we're going to
attempt to go to a donation center right
now and see if they'll take us as a
walk-in so fingers crossed that we're
able to donate today and if not then
we'll just make an appointment for later
on this month and then we'll just go
back so we're trying to do this before
we go to Vegas like at least for me I
feel like it's like my moral
responsibility since I'm a Type O and
I'm a universal donor I feel like I need
to contribute like however much I can
going to a place that is you know in the
midst of a crisis and you know that's
morning it feels wrong to go there and
not be a part of the help exam and it's
not like we wouldn't want to help if we
weren't going to Vegas you know but it's
because we're going there like first
hand we have the chance to actually help
right then and there as
the city is still coping with everything
that's happened there I feel compelled
to you know donate what haven't donated
blood in a long time now I used to be
really into donating blood when I was in
high school I really I called it you
yeah almost like every time there was a
blood donation drive
I would definitely donate blood and I
don't know what happened like just being
a grown-up and then you know you get
busy and then you're looking out for
number one and you know you kind of have
to make a living and grownup matters and
interests and you forget about the
humanitary
you know responsibility that you know
you should be doing and so this is like
for me it's like a return to form before
my innocence was lost being a grown-up
no for me I always tried to donate blood
at high in high school I alway time that
there was a blood drive I would go and
sign up in every single time they would
deny me because I never weighed enough
like I was always like 95 pounds you
have to be at least 110 and now I am
like a hundred and I think hundred and
I'm really like I'm barely making it I
remember a few years back my hospital
that I was working in had a blood drive
and again I went and I attempted to see
if I could donate blood and they said
that my iron levels were too low so I
finally made the weight but then my iron
levels were too low so I'm like no so
then I waited again the next year that
they came back and I made sure I ate a
lot of spinach a lot of lentils and eggs
and like every iron-rich food that I
could think of like I just ate as much
as I could and so I'm like trying to do
my best to make sure that I'm healthy
enough and you drink enough water I did
I should I'm drinking water right now I
still need a drink more but hopefully
they accept us we'll see you ready let's
do it
get those veins ready I'm not a very
veiny person they're gonna put like 5
holes in me today because it happens all
the time I end up getting like 5
boo-boos Oh your boo-boos boo-boos no
I'm super rainy I have like the greatest
veins ever like people that the
phlebotomist they love by veins look at
that one nice and fluffy I'm ready let's
do it let's go
all right so we've just spent about an
hour waiting to see if they could see us
but they said that they've been having a
lot of people come in and people that
have appointments obviously take
priority over walk-ins
so we ended up making an appointment for
later on this month so we'll be back to
donate now the plan is I'm gonna go get
my nails done find some more frivolous
things don't hate yeah all right I'm
leaving
what are you doing what's happening he's
the coffee from IHOP and the water I was
drinking to give blood okay bye I gotta
go okay you're gonna see me with new
nail colors I'm thinking black since
Halloween's coming up anyways and I
haven't had black nails since I was in
my emo grunge stay bye cutie pie look at
him I want to put my face in his belly
jealous yeah a little bit that cute bye
right I gotta be alright I'm not to do
my nails
[Music]
all right so I'm all done with my nails
I ended up going with the matte black
you see the matte black the camera won't
focus like always see what I tell you
guys I'm all focused there we go
a matte black we're getting ready for
Halloween so if you guys are curious I
get my nails with hard gel not just
typical regular nail polish it's not
acrylic it's not normal gel its hardtail
so talking to all the ladies out there
and know what I'm talking about because
I know the guys are gonna be like huh
it's not for you it's for the girls so
the hard gel it's like this really thick
substance gooey kind of thing that leave
your nails feeling like it's acrylic but
it's healthier than acrylic apparently
like it lets your nails breathe a little
more I'm not sure exactly the scientific
thing about it but my girl suggested to
try hard gel so for the last I would say
maybe like about six months I've been
doing hard gel and that's how I was able
to grow up my nose really long so I
don't have any fake tips on these are
100% mine except for the hard gel on top
of it so yeah I mean I've been loving it
it's like way lighter like it just it
just feels really sturdy cuz if I don't
have anything on my nails like I give
it's just regular nail polish my nails
break so easily they're so brittle so
guess I need to take vitamins because I
have really weak nails with the hard
gentle I think I get them done maybe
like once every two months so I get to
come weigh less it is more expensive
obviously than regular gel but it's
worth it for me so anyway so now that
I'm done I'm gonna stop by pick up some
poop gift for the huffy and then see
what he's up to
supposedly he's editing but I bet you
anything he's just watching a whole
bunch of trailers huh aren't you future
Casey alright so we're all done with
lunch did you like your polka bebut see
we hi oh
I mean that's a yes yes so we're all
done with lunch now and what I really
wanted to do was show you guys and also
to show our future selves like you know
I'm thinking like 20 years from now and
then we're looking back on these videos
I wanted to remember in video form our
wedding gifts that we received because
we have some really amazing friends
family and fans who sent us things and I
was really excited I wanted to show you
guys alright so this first one we have
here so this was given to Casey by a fan
which I don't remember because there
were a few bottles and then Bart and Joe
got one too and it is don't don't look
don't look I'm trying to take good like
it's Perry Perry's up come on focus
camera Mondo's peri-peri sauce so that's
for you have you ever had Nando's I
never have you never been to the
hemisphere of the world where they have
Nando's yet never I've only ever seen in
Australia I've heard this before
what where they have Nando's all over
the world and they even have like a
challenge or if you visit every single
location around the world you get like a
permanent some sort of like membership
or something yeah so sorry fan who gave
that to Casey I don't remember who you
were but thank you I will call him Perry
Perry name is Perry nando as far as I'm
concerned thanks Perry and then we got
these gifts which I haven't opened yeah
I just opened the box but this is from
Hannah from Sweden this is a candle made
in my hometown of Boris sweet and me
give you many wonderful smelling nights
you're so sweet Hannah thank you so much
totally appreciate this they're gonna
smell this handle
see what it sounds like oh cool we have
Swedish newspaper - I only have one hand
help me what a pretty candle it's not oh
it smells really good Oh what is it
smells like Sweden Swedish neighbor hurt
over City Boris I'm a little obsessed
with how people live lives elsewhere so
this newspaper is actually very
interesting I know it's pretty cool she
even gave us another mini present
without knowing oh look at this blanket
oh can you help me again need your hand
[Applause]
this is so cool it's so fluffy and soft
and oh yeah it is like water is a
Spanish a little while ago and this is
for my cousin Samantha who attended the
wedding and she lives out in Paris thank
you so much
Sammy we already opened this present but
I wanted to show you guys Uncle Pete she
is insanely thoughtful look at the same
you guys have to see this look how cute
very cute in case yours threw me on my
hike man yep she wrote such a sweet
thing okay I'm not gonna read it is
pretty long but it's not like her
writing though she has a really nice
Henry maybe you guys can just read it
really quick on your own fun the Star
Wars song starts now and go Thank You
Sammy you're so sweet and then she also
got a this bracelet from Paris created
with love in Paris and his love and it's
a cute little bracelet it says French
tea is Mary
I don't know what that means but I think
this this brand is like marriage team
Paris teatime I don't know France is
known for tea Irby tea oh I kind of
smells I don't know that's giving the
candle records money smells pretty good
[Laughter]
also super cool Tagalog and then she's
like for your future travels together
isn't that so thoughtful and then we can
like scratch off where we've been and
it's like a whole book thing and then we
can plan our trips I'm definitely gonna
be using this and then she also threw in
here this already opened it I thought it
was a no these people know that that's a
bag to keep you on airplanes for you to
throw up in I don't know yeah and then
we got some more candles
it's like limey like zesty mm-hmm lemony
fresh that's what we got from my cousin
Samantha and then our good friends their
company name is I loot papery and steal
the paper their paper pant bend it's so
cute their whole branding so I'm gonna
put the link in the description you have
to check out their cards what they do
they have a company and they make these
super super adorable cards or best
wishes or out-of-this-world adventures
together and it says just married and so
they create these cards it's so cute and
they wrote us like a really sweet
message and then it says cards you guys
can write to Isaac
como se llaman rato is acute acute is
cars so this one is for Tiffany to write
to Casey services for me to write to you
says job well done you're in rare form
because I like food there's no one I
like better than you I love our you like
no other
I do you bacon me crazy I lie down I'm
[ __ ] you too cute little art last but
not least here we have or case you to
write for Tiffany let's Mack and be
cheesy oh that's a cool you're a fine
pizza I like that one do ya you so foxy
you foxy I've got nothing but love for
you so if you guys are looking for
really cute adorable cards to send to
your and not your typical hallmark type
stuff yeah that's it I want to show you
guys what we got and then oh wait and
then this thing to go Casey's friend
from Dallas who went to our wedding
along with his wife not he gifted us
this beautiful cutting board that he
made himself and then he carved out a
TNC and then the wedding date which is
so thoughtful
and it was really sweet of them to do
that because we had told everyone that
went to the wedding like please don't
worry about giving this gift like we
just you guys being there is enough for
us the fact that dick did that was
really really sweet
oh you know who else gave us something
it's upstairs next to our TV oh yeah
we're in G other um what do you call it
sound bar is that our do bar thing but
it pretty much gives us
surround sound doesn't it with that
thing yeah because remember I put on the
the head thing and then I have to like
then in different parts of the room so
it could like thank you for in geo for
that wouldn't present to then and then
up obviously in cases family who gave
him this beautiful bracelet beautiful
necklace that I never take off and then
Casey's parents gifted us some hula
thank you what about me what about I
give you I gave you something you gave
me your life and then when I give you
huh biome yeah so those are our wedding
presents we're we're so blessed baby
[Music]